make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking back up again with the
war of realms this is actually the
conclusion I mean there's a conclusion
of this which is actually pretty legit
like it's it's pretty solid
and I actually really really dug it now
here's here's kind of the funny thing
though
Odin's son is kind of an idiot and the
reason why is because like this whole
thing he picks I remember like Odin and
Freya like force parents had basically
been captured by Malekith and so the way
the whole is kind of like berry or
magical barrier had been established by
Malekith was to ensure that no other
Avengers nobody besides Thor came in did
only Thor could pass through it himself
what Thor ended up doing was actually
going to the going to the Norns the tree
of Idris Hill and then in turn like
taking out one of his eyes basically
like hosting himself an eye for wisdom
and then like basically learning the way
to essentially defeat Malekith now this
is kind of ironic for two reasons one
because again Thor is kind of an idiot I
guess own sons kind of an idiot and two
he's done this before
for people who are looking at this show
like but I already thought four took an
eye out and that's true but that was
during the events of Ragnarok when Thor
came back during J michael Straczynski
's run after Ragnarok he had both of his
eyes and he has ever since and the idea
here is that much like we saw during the
Ragnarok event in order to basically
gain the wisdom of Odin he had to follow
the same steps as Odin which was to
remove one of his eyes and so what that
basically meant was that he saw
essentially the the way to defeat
Malekith now the other reason that Routh
is like a reason here the reason why I
say that Odin sons kind of an idiot is
because what he ends up learning is that
the only way to defeat Malekith is to
get all the versions of himself from
across time and ban them together in
order to fight now it's kind of funny
because he's done that before and you
would think like that'd be his first
thing right like well I mean we defeated
God butcher when we all came together
from like three different time periods
so like let's do that again but you
think he would figure it out on his own
but I guess not weird it's kind of
ironic still the funny thing about this
is that when they all sort to band
together it really is in a lot of ways
it's kind of a sinned off right and
that's kind of the irony of this is
because when I look at this and I look
at the idea of them making a return and
truth like I would have switched him and
I would have had like this this like
this war of realms basically kind of the
circumstance anyway like with Malekith
and all that I would have done that in
place of like God butcher and then I
would have made God butcher a villain
that everybody had to face off against
right because god butcher was super
strong he had the all black necro sort
of a null the soviet god he had like all
these crazy abilities he was super
powerful and it took like like all three
Thor's couldn't really even beat him at
the same time like he managed like ended
up taking Thor using two hammers and the
power of the all-black necro sword in
order to
to feed Gor the god butcher so it's kind
of crazy because when you sit them
side-by-side this almost kind of seems a
little anticlimactic Emerton you know in
comparison what we saw at the very
beginning of Jason Aaron's run with the
god butchers storyline having said that
they got butcher story line was so good
did it really is kind of hard to top
that like it was pretty amazing like it
was it was pretty stellar but we
basically have like moderate like like
present-day Odin son we've got his
future version right so like the
all-father thor like from from however
many millennia into the future and then
you've got his past self and then of
course you have Jane Foster so you gotta
have like these different iterations of
Thor now the funny thing about this is
remember Mjolnir had basically been
thrown into the Sun right in the belief
was that it had been destroyed or at the
very least was beyond reach for like
Odin's son to go and grab himself the
funny thing is that what Jane Foster had
done as she had actually reformed the
hammer of Thor from like the ultimate
universe right like the war for
essentially like reforming his hammer
that he had he had taken after Thor from
the ultimate universe that lost it and
but it's really just kind of being held
together by what's essentially like
shoestrings right let's shoot he's
literally like it's on ass last leg
after having been reformed but at the
very least like that the cool thing
about this is the kind of address of the
situation's like hey they're kind of a
ragtag band right like they're running
on what they have they're like the Rebel
Alliance from Star Wars right like
they're just kind of it's like a
shoestring budget basically keeping
everything together hope is the only
thing that keeps them alive you know by
by all standards of measurement so you
essentially have like like for for the
past remember at that point in his past
had not become worthy enough to Lilith
mill near because he hadn't faced off
against a hella in order to saved sift
so he hadn't reached that point in his
history yet but then you've also got
modern-day Odin's son you've got Jane
Foster and then you've got future Thor
so you got four Thor's who basically
come racing into this place and it's
kind of a funny thing because when that
happens Malek it's response is okay but
like only Thor should be able to access
this and it's like yeah but it's all
Thor's from different time periods which
seems to be the one thing that Malekith
didn't account for now the other thing
about this too is it Malekith has
actually bonded himself to the Venom
symbiote now here's here's a crazy thing
about that when it came to the venom
tie-in for war of realms that dealt with
eddie brock and we didn't really know
what was gonna be happening with the
venom Simien and it kind of makes sense
because with the way the tie-in was done
a lot of the emphasis has kind of been
focused directly on Eddie Brock in terms
of where he goes next which is really a
large portion of what the venom story
was about because of the fact that you
had like Eddie getting the Venom
symbiote back and the two of them kind
of working together and like their first
conflict was with nola symbiote god and
then following that i went to the
revelation
like Eddie Brock had a son following
trends if history repeats itself then
like the tie-ins will basically still
focus on like the main brunt of the
story in terms of whatever that Heian
happens to pertain to in this instance
pertaining to venom so it makes sense
that it would focus on Eddie Brock and
not the simian and so with with Malekith
bonding himself to the symbiote is
actually kind of crazy because one of
the things that seems to happen here is
we don't hear the voice of the simian we
just see like literally Malekith using
it for his own ends now it's kind of
crazy because when this happens and he
pops up he's got a crazy-looking face
and you know he's got his wings and so
on but the funny thing here is that
Malekith does not use the venom simia to
its full totality and the reason why is
because he just doesn't know how and
that's one of the important things to
bear in mind that's one of the reasons
why when lee price got the Venom
symbiote he didn't have like the full
power of the symbiote because he didn't
know how to use an innocent tire it
wasn't until like Eddie Brock got it
back there was like a whole new host of
powers for the symbiote because Eddie
was able to push it to its limits and
then go a little bit further after nul
had woke up some of the powers that it
previously had that we didn't know about
but this fight that goes on is
simultaneous between the fights are like
The Secret Avengers and the frost giants
of so on it wraps up pretty quickly like
it wraps up pretty fast but one thing
that I want to draw your attention to is
that while all of this is happening
while all these fights are cross you
know these realms and these forces of of
Malekith are taking place that energy is
emanating from the Sun a storm is
brewing so to speak you know no pun
intended but energy is emanating from
the Sun and it's kind of crazy because
as that goes on you end up having some
of these some of these trolls who are
watching this thing unfold and what they
do is they basically say like like in
the beginning there was ice and there
was fire and that was it and that really
sees me what's going on here energy and
light at least cold energy like frost
energy and then heat energy from the Sun
and one of the trolls comments that says
this is how everything began this is how
all life originated now remember when it
comes to the Asgardian legends in terms
of where life began and you know with
regards to the creation of everything
that's really relegated to a scart and
Marvel is pretty well accepted with you
know that Odin did not create everything
in existence right that's just kind of
Norwegian mythology release as as
Guardian mythology and then that's
basically yet rather that's really all
you get there so it's really kind of
isolated and alone but what they're
doing is you're basically saying like
something's being created here life is
being given now the other cool thing
about this is that when you have the The
Secret Avengers right so like Captain
America's guys and those those folks who
were facing off against uh against lafi
the king of the frost giants in
Jotunheim he actually consumes the
casket of ancient winters
you don't know the casket of ancient
winters is this this little literally
like this box that if you open it up it
releases the infinite cold of Jotunheim
a lot of you guys saw it in the original
Thor movie that uh that giant casket
looking thing that Loki was holding on
to you when you first learned that he
was basically part frost giant that's
the casket of ancient winters you can
channel that energy and you can even
blanket infinite cold across whatever
landscape you want to use and that's
what lafi intensity where I like lafi
his intention is to basically like like
defeat all these guys here encase them
all in cold and then travel to Midgard
travel to earth and then unleash the
power of the casket of ancient winters
which is kind of cool because in truth
like that was really one of malok his
first big schemes when a malakut first
showed up in Marvel Comics one of his
first big schemes was to steal the
casket of ancient winters and open it up
on Midgard and of course he was defeated
and he was stopped but it's cool to kind
of see you know a Jason Aaron make these
little hints to like the history of the
Thor mythos and really with the villain
of Malekith but with with all these
Thor's showing up and and going it's
Malekith himself the reality is that he
was totally unprepared for this and the
reason why is because when it comes to
Malekith as a character he's really more
of a magical entity right so it's like
Doctor Strange and Doctor Strange is
very very powerful when it comes to like
magic and sorcery but he's not much of a
fist fighter right I mean if you throw
him in like a fistfight with like the
Punisher who's gotta get the crap beat
out of him because he's really gonna
magic he's not really good at fighting
Malekith is much the same way I mean
granted he has the enhancements and the
various attributes that come along with
someone who's of Asgardian mythos right
so like enhanced strength and speed and
durability and all that kind of cool
stuff but when you're talking about him
facing off against Thor that's gonna be
a challenge for him in and of himself if
he's not really able to wield magic you
haven't facing off against for Thor's
and all the magic in the world is not
gonna help because it's just gonna be
way too much strength way too much raw
power for him to be able to defeat on
his own and that's where his his
cockiness really begins to get the
better of him and the reason why is
because Malekith is aware of who null is
right like the symbiote got he knows you
know is he knows the power null possess
and so because of that when he bombs
himself to the symbiote his hubris gets
carried away
he basically fancies himself a god and
very high above his station like much
higher above his station than he
actually is and so the result is that
when he when he faces off against these
Thor's he's able to get the upper hand
for a short amount of time but at the
end of the day like once this energy
starts to reform it starts to coalesce
than the Sun and suddenly everybody's
made aware of what it is that's
happening we end up finding out that
what's been going on
the hammer of Mjolnir has been reformed
and it returns right back down to earth
and crashes in front of Odin's son it's
always the coolest thing because he in
turn goes and picks it up and Odin's son
gets Mele near back and so like when he
gets that well then the battles over
like it's basically done this fight ends
like gap it's it's the craziest thing
but it's kind of cool because for those
who are our fans of Thor we're like
those who were fans of Thor and who have
been reading comics for a long time we
all basically knew this is exactly what
was gonna happen right for the new
leaders they didn't really know because
I mean they have learned they haven't
really been reading comics long enough
to see the kind of patterns that you see
but from the time Thor lost his or I
guess Odin's son losses hammer until
like now it was only ever a matter time
until he got it back until he was
absolutely worthy of wielding his hammer
again right and that's kind of the cool
theme because this is like a singular
cohesive story or so it's like treating
it like it's six issues that spread over
multiple years with multiple issues so
again it's the nature of comics things
change and then they always go back to
the way they were before it always
happens that way so don't get too torn
up over things changing they always go
back after a while you just learn to
realize the pattern and see what's going
on it's like okay cool like another
really good example
Loki was eaten by lafi and he was
believed to have been dead only to cut
himself out so again like it's
everything always goes back to the
status quo it always has and always will
I mean just read comics long enough and
I promise you I promise you you will see
it happen right like heroes reborn
heroes return it's the nature of things
we have the actual heroes reborn story
arc and the actual heroes return story
arc is it really what I'm referring to
heroes returns sucked but nonetheless
getting back into this getting back into
the story proper because of the fact
that that that Odin's son has Mjolnir
back this was really kind of designed to
highlight the power of Mjolnir just what
it's capable of and that's one of the
cool things is that if you were really
kind of reading between the lines and
you were really sort of looking at like
the contextual circumstance the way this
played out was like once Miller was gone
and then the war of rums began hope was
was wasn't really lost so much as things
were very very bleak but with Mjolnir
coming back because you're talking about
a hammer that is by all standards of
measurement nearly indestructible and is
now back in the hands of Odin's son then
it's just a countdown to when everything
ends it's designed to say hey here's
what happens when Odin's son or really
like anybody bearing the mantle of Thor
gets Mjolnir back then like they win and
that's basically it
as that's basically the way this goes
and so like literally when I say this
fight ends like super quick I mean it
ends in like three pages like literally
like the hammer comes back Malekith gets
hit in the face
and then he gets carried away and that's
basically it he literally gets torn to
pieces and carried away
and that's basically it like he's done
now and it's kind of like wow like that
fast huh that quick huh it's kind of
supported to see it in that fast but
there are a few things that come out of
this one of the cool things that come
out of this is that we're actually going
to see like future crossovers between
Wolverine and Punisher which we've seen
them before but they usually fought it
looks like we're gonna be seeing in the
future it like are like team ups between
Wolverine of the Punisher which I'm
actually really really excited about um
daredevil of course loses the eye side
of heimdal he you know Heimdall
basically goes back to being his normal
self and and daredevil goes back to
being blind
the venom send me at oddly enough the
venom see me because of the fact that he
was basically you know possessed by a
being of dark magic
when Malekith was freed the Venom
symbiote went back to its normal self
right like regained its mind essentially
and so now we're gonna see how that
follows up going into Donnie Cates his
venom Jane Foster we don't know what's
gonna happen to her if I'm a betting man
I would say this she would take over the
role of the Valkyries right she's gonna
become the new Valkyrie because all the
doctors are dead right there all bases
they were they were all killed off it's
like she's gonna become the new Valkyrie
that makes the most sense to me Loki of
course goes back to doing the Loki stuff
going and going back to doing like
mischievous things but probably the
biggest set of events here the biggest
change to come out of all of this is
that following the defeat of Malekith
and all of his forces everything
returning to the status quo the one big
change that comes out
Odin steps aside and says you are now
the all-father which is really Jason
Aaron's way of explaining how it is that
Thor became that character in the future
anyway I mean we were always kind of
left to assume that Odin just died
somewhere along the line either he died
in battle with like Serdar or he just
died of old age or whatever the case
says because because as Guardians can
die of old age he basically died in that
left the mantel open for Thor instead
that doesn't happen instead what goes on
here is Odin actually steps aside and
says you are now the new all-father like
you are you are now the new ruler of
Asgard you are essentially the new Odin
it's pretty sweet is it's pretty badass
so that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rock war if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]